en el cielo de jartum las mismas nubes
de humo negro Día tras día en la capital
sudanesa continúan los combates a pesar
de una nueva tregua que debía entrar en
vigor el lunes por la noche como
resultado la entrega de ayuda
humanitaria sigue siendo imposible en
yua Sudán del sur se cargan alimentos en
aviones y camiones están a la espera de
poder salir
necesitamos enviar al menos 100 camiones
a cartoon recoger a la gente y abrir
parte de la carretera hacia el norte de
barelgazal y parte de la carretera hacia
el sur para que nuestra gente pueda ser
evacuada con seguridad
también se esperaba que el alto el fuego
al que se llegó en Arabia Saudita abrirá
corredores humanitarios seguros para
evacuar a los miles de civiles que
siguen atrapados en medio de los
combates
los civiles son especialmente
vulnerables la ONU Ya documentado varias
decenas de casos de violencia sexual y
lanza un nuevo llamado desesperado para
que cesen las hostilidades
deben dar instrucciones claras e
inequívocas a todos los que están Bajo
su mando díganles que hay tolerancia
cero para la violencia sexual que los
autores de todas las violaciones tendrán
que rendir cuentas hay que salvar a la
población civil y Ustedes deben poner
fin a esta violencia sin sentido Ya
el conflicto que estalló el 15 de abril
ha dejado ya más de 1800 muertos y más
de un millón de desplazados según un
recuento de la ONU